do you think that people should follow
their dreams and along those lines if
they should follow their dreams when
should an artist leave their day job oh
that's that's a tricky one it's a really
tricky question because there's a part
of me I'll give you this is my committee
giving this several answers ok there's a
part of me that says don't leave you
don't leave your day job until it
becomes absolutely impossible to stay in
it because of the dream you're following
see how long you can stay in the day job
and I'm just thinking about security and
all that then there's another part that
says I'll leave it just go at any time
now I'm and some in some ways I'm not a
great person to ask this because when I
started in this business I've had very
few quote day jobs I've been I just been
able to create a lot of jobs to create a
lot of work or do a lot of things that I
wanted to do and then at times years and
years and years ago 30 40 years ago I
had day jobs while I was still pursuing
this but as soon as I got a job
directing or a job something in the
business day job was gone immediately so
I was one of those that would just quit
immediately but then sometimes months
later I would find myself in deep
trouble because that job was over the
job I did it was fine that done but
there was no job following it and then I
was found myself scrambling again to put
something together at least to support
myself so I don't you know but the
following of the dreams I think the big
question is do you have a plan do you
have a vision of how you're going to
pursue what you want and this is also
from personal experience I've at times
unfortunately relied too heavily on jobs
show
or someone helping me out and not taking
care of it myself
then I've swung the other way and
created a whole business on my own to
support myself which is instill in my
business which I'm doing now to support
myself so I've gone both both ways I
think it's looking at what is what is my
plan what is my plan for today or let's
put it this way this has something to do
with what else and I are looking into
now is what your dream where do you
imagine you would be five years from now
following your dream can you imagine
where you would be and what and just
write about what that is and describe
what that is okay now come back wait
where would you be five months from now
in that dream describe that okay then
you come back where would you be five
days from now following your dream and
can you describe that now you've
described goals and pinpoints and then
the last thing is what can you do in the
next hour to fulfill that dream doing
that you'll start to see possibly a plan
a goal a map of some sort I think too
many people are following a dream so I
want to be a great actress I want to be
a great writer but there's no map
there's no I'm gonna I'm going to write
a screenplay three screenplays this year
three different genres that's a plan can
you do that while you have your day job
sure you can so I think it's a matter of
really being realistic about not just
what the dream is but what how you
envision you might get there chances are
it won't work exactly that way but
chances are if you have that vision
you're gonna come somewhat closer or at
least be moving in that direction are
you almost relieved that you didn't take
a day job you know you said you would
work at one directing
or something then as many industry jobs
the one but if you have had something
more cush or that it was just more
stable then you wouldn't have created
what you've created more core stable
like what well if you just had like this
steady job after job you said sometimes
you you waited and you've relied too
much on a job being there for you and
and maybe it wasn't at times maybe that
was a painful lesson um do you think
that in some ways I was a good painful
lesson because then it ignited in you to
start you know what you started and
right and do these classes and and the
Travis Institute and all these other
things yeah it's I mean it did the
everything I'm doing now that Ella and I
are doing out together which started
many many years ago was generated was
started out of that desperation out of
that desperation I have to do something
and because of who I am or whatever my
personality what I did not pursue was a
typical day job whether it's waiting on
tables or working for a company or
something like that my fallback has
always been create something so I would
create a job and that was creating
workshops that I was teaching first for
actors and then for directors and I
would keep creating something that
didn't exist that I could do which would
keep me close to what I was doing anyway
I didn't want to go and work and you
know 9:00 to 5:00 and some come you know
office building I just that would be
just too devastating to me and too
demoralizing for me so that's what I
would do but I would wait a long time
before doing that until it was desperate
and then I would have to put something
together rather quickly to keep
everything going then ironically with
the teaching that I was doing it became
more than just a day job
it became an entire business became an
entire business that you know resulted
in what I'm doing now which is traveling
around the world and teaching and many
times I go
what happened to my other job the
directing thing all the other stuff I
was doing because this has become so
[Music]
Madhu and now with Elsa what the Elsa
and I are doing together
that's it has taken over and sometimes I
think what would happen what would
happen now if I was offered a directing
thing well we'd have to make some big
shifts and changes so but that and
that's okay but that that's the way my
life has always been it's always been a
bit chaotic and under my control which
means sometimes out of control but at
the end of the day you're still working
with story still doing this as something
you love yeah yeah I if well if you're
gonna create something might as well
create something you enjoy doing so I
wouldn't create something I enjoy doing
or that I knew I was good at and that I
could survive at if I could just
construct something along the line so
the teaching and the coaching and the
consulting and all of that falls right
in that although it's not directing but
you know it's all around it as this and
all my directing skills and my writing
skills you know supply that support that
that process so I'm not that far away
from what I was doing
in fact I've moved way beyond what I was
doing so again going back to when should
an artist create one should an artist
quit their day job it's when it becomes
unbearable at that day job unbearable or
their other thing becomes undeniable in
terms of supporting them a bearable
undeniable yeah yeah that's it's sort of
in that zone reasons I'm hesitating this
because I just remembered something that
happened to me they were again doing a
lot of the teaching stuff there was a
time this is back in the early
nice and I was teaching a lot of
workshops and doing you know doing what
I was doing teaching workshops and and
and trying to get directing jobs and
through a series of circumstances which
are not important right at the moment I
got a job directing a feature film for
Warner Brothers okay and there was a
long story on how that all happened
that's not important
and I important part is okay now I'm
directing this film it's a low-budget
film but it's for a major studio and I'm
getting all the studio's support and
everything's going fine
and I'm still doing my others I'm still
running workshops I'm doing everything
else I was and I'm used to doing 12
things at the same time anyway and
that's what my life was like and I would
have clients over to work with and I
remember one meeting and we're going
into pre-production with the producers
from Warner Brothers sat me down and say
mark you have to stop doing these other
things and I go why you know one
workshop was on Wednesday evening I'll
be free on Wednesday evenings the other
ones I could do on weekends I'm free on
weekends no no no mark
you have to you are directing this film
yeah you had that has to be your sole
focus and I remember resenting that I
don't want to do that I want to do these
other things too and ironically I did
shut down all the other things but the
irony is now we're deep into
pre-production and we're working Monday
through Friday and I have a student at
the studio and had my office and we was
setting everything up and I remember
hitting the first weekend and everybody
said okay it was Friday
okay see you on Monday I go on Monday
well what are we doing Saturday and
Sunday nothing well what am I gonna do
Saturday and Sunday I was so used to
working seven days a week doing
something every single day now it shut
down all the other stuff and now I
didn't have that other thing so I had to
make a whole shift
in my way of approaching the work I mean
it was absolutely right you know I
needed to totally focus on the film and
I and I did and all that but that was a
ship so I think for anybody considering
making that kind of change think about
what you're used to and what your
patterns are and what you can handle and
what you can't handle and what the day
job is and my feeling is if you get to
the point you say I better quit the day
job because there's other stuff that I'm
doing which is my dream is demanding so
much of my time and attention and I say
well then it's time to quit it's time to
quit what did you end up doing for the
first few Saturdays and Sundays of that
directing job it was it was hard it was
it was really hard because there was
nobody in the office nobody I could talk
to you know I go back and I'd read the
script again and I'd make notes and they
would do do my own research or planning
but I'm the type of artist who loves to
collaborate I loved other people being
around so I'd love being at the studio I
loved working with the designers and I
loved working with the casting director
I loved working with all this people and
something you leave me for two days and
nobody to talk to and I felt lost anyway
I was like we could be home with my
family that's fine but I wanted to do
that I wanted to I really literally I
think at that time wanted to why can't
we work through the weekend so why do we
have to stop for the weekend but that's
just my personality it's a great story
yeah I like that so then when that job
was over you knew it was that was that
your test when ironically when that job
was over and now I had a terrific agency
not an agent but an agency working for
me and I was reading a lot of scripts
because I was directing of a studio
picture and scripts were being sent to
me to see if I was interested in it and
all of the said yeah
thing and I was trying the the goal now
is set up the next project because this
project is coming near an end set up the
next project and I without I can't
mention the agencies and all that is my
agent the big agency said you know I
said let's set up the next project and
they said to me that the Aged agency
said to me well let's see how this movie
does first and I'll never forget this
and I was sitting there and there were
inquiries from other studios about
things and I said well can we set some
let's see how this film does first and I
knew at that moment because we're near
we're near the end of post-production
that the film was not going to do well
for a lot of reasons I knew that it's
not it's not gonna be like wow let's
hire this guy even though the reactions
to the footage and the reactions to the
performances all were great and
everything I said it's not going to do
well and I knew why and I said to the
agent
I said listen if the film does really
well I don't need you if it doesn't do
well you can't help me I said we have to
do it now and they said no and I knew
that that was the end of my relationship
with that agency and it was I switched
agents but the film did not do well I
did not get another job set up and I was
doing fine because the film paid well
but then that's only gonna last so long
and it was months later still trying to
set up the next job that I realized I
have to do something to generate income
I can't go back and do theater now
because it'll take me too long to set up
a play that I'm going to direct at a
local theater I can't go back to
television because I've been out of
television for too long and it's going
to take time I need in other words I
need income now and so I started
teaching and that's when the that was
the beginning of the whole teaching
thing that has led to where I am now and
then in between you've written two books
written two books as well and there's
another one in the works which will be
done someday yep that's a great story
I'm sure it's a painful one at that time
yeah oh yeah that's a great story it's
very painful to be they'll tell you when
they Israeli people at that studio which
is a big studio and we were shooting on
a lot that was not at that studio so the
times I would go to that studio and
people would see me while we were
shooting come on love you film love you
till I go to your dailies every day oh
and this is these are people who are not
working on the film they just at the
studio they would just go to see the
stuff that we shot so you have all that
there that that build-up that sort of
support and feeling like wow I'm I'm
doing well I'm doing well here all of
that and then during post-production
which is I could tell you this whole
story post-production and how it all
slowly fell apart sometimes because of
distrust sometimes because of sabotage
by other people and sometimes because of
infighting inside the studio because
there were studio executives who wanted
the film to fail and all I ran into and
at the very end of that whole journey
with that studio I was asked to meet
with the head of the studio was a sweet
guy nice guy we had a long talk about
and he said mark you were just in the
wrong place at the wrong time
I got one that doesn't help me at all so
it was very it was very painful when you
think okay now the career is starting to
move now I'm moving and now I'm doing
well and now they like the work they
like me and all that but
you